so look you've seen the articles about
you know people are concerned about Ai
and Elon Musk and Steve Wozniak wrote
this open letter with another thousand
people saying let's pump the brakes on
AI for six months but what part of AI is
so deeply concerning to these guys
recently six days ago the president of
Microsoft Brad Smith said the following
he said deep fakes are his biggest
concern about AI this is when he was
speaking to a group of government
officials members of Congress and policy
experts last Thursday in Washington when
he shared the same he fears deep fakes
will help create more misinformation and
by the way it's not just him let's look
at Google CEO here's what he had to say
Sundar pichai conceded in a 60-minute
interview with CBS he said AI will make
it easier to create fake news and fake
images including videos hence deep fakes
and by the way this deep fake is
multi-dimensional it's not just about
Voice or video which we'll cover that
here in a minute it's Gal Gadot the
actress Wonder Woman's in a porn but
it's a deep fake or all these pictures
of Donald Trump getting arrested when he
went to court or deep fakes about the
Pentagon being blown up to the point
where the news one of the most reputable
new sources in India's reporting on it
and the stock market collapsed because
of a deep fake this is a real issue and
we're going to talk about that today
today's sponsor Better Health whether
you're rich poor middle class married
not married careers do well but
relationships that sometimes you want to
talk to somebody in discreet about your
personal life we just don't want to do
it where you go to a therapist at an
office and everyone's waiting there and
they kind of say hey well Johnny what
are you doing here oh well I was about
to see the therapist there is a solution
for that better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online at Better Health you can tap into
a network of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues to get started you just have to
answer a few questions about your needs
and preferences and therapy that way
better health can match you with the
right therapist from their Network then
you can talk to the therapist however
you feel comfortable whether it's via
text chat phone or video call you can
message your therapist at any time and
schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you and by the way if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a noon
therapist at any time for no additional
charge get 10 off your first month by
going to betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment the link is also below so
whether you go to betterhelp.com forward
slash valuetainment or you click on the
link below you get 10 off for your first
month so look if you give value out of
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel so let's get right into
it look a lot of people will say well
deep fix our new thing now this has got
to be something new it just started in
the last 5 10 15 years no the first time
we had a deep fake was an 1898 by Thomas
Edison the Edison Company wanted to film
the Spanish-American War but the low
quality cameras made it challenging
Edison chose to mix real footage of
marching soldiers and weaponry with
Stage footage of American soldiers by
manipulating the truth the footage had
the desired effect of fueling patriotism
in America this shows that the intent of
deep fakes Is Not A New Concept once
again Thomas Edison started deep fakes
before anybody else did so so now that's
from the 1898 but if we look at today
with the different kind of deep fakes
we've had the last five years here's a
timeline DHS did a guideline or report
on this if you have not seen this report
it's phenomenal to take a look at is
very helpful they show a timeline from
2018 starting with President Obama's
BuzzFeed deep fake and then they talk
about Jama Casa's deep fake to Jennifer
Lawrence to David Beckham to world
leaders sing and imagine all of these
things whether it's Tom Cruise Mark
Zuckerberg they have them all including
Joe Rogan and they categorize it into
different types of deep fakes puppet
deep fake here's what puppet deep fake
looks like and this stuff is not hard to
get a hold of the second one they call
is a mouth swap deep fake there's plenty
of apps that can do it as well here's
what it looks like which our enemies can
make it look like anyone is saying
anything the third one is a face swap
deep fake and here's the example of what
it looks like I've been thinking and I
realized that it's been almost 10 years
the next one is a synthetic media deep
fake and this is what it looks like
a press conference in the Rose Garden
and then you have the audio deep fakes
and this is what Morgan Freeman sounds
like saying I'm not Morgan Freeman I am
not Morgan Freeman and what you see is
not real so let's look at the data to
see how big of a deal this is like are
we really getting that big of a growth
and the number of deep fakes being done
here's what the data looks like in 2019
we had roughly 14.6 million deep fakes
in 2020 that doubled to 29.2 then 43.8
then 58.4 2023 they're expected to have
a
106.4 million total deep fakes imagine
the influence and the manipulation on
that and by the way there was a study
done by Deep trade saying that 96 of all
deep fake videos they found were
non-consensual pornographic featuring
women that's the Deep fake industry
today so let's look at some of the
evolutional technology on how deep fakes
were made back in 1997 we had a video
rewrite program this program would first
track facial movements in the video and
then it would rewrite the video with
synthesized facial expressions then they
evolved to 2001 the active appearance
model this model would consider the
shape and appearance color and texture
of a face and binds these into a single
unified model then in 2014 they came out
with a generative adversarial networks
this consisted of two parts a generator
Network which creates the image in a
discriminator network which tries to
tell the difference between real and
generated images and today we have
plenty apps you can download to do deep
fakes and you can even look like Tom
Cruise and go viral and have a massive
Tick Tock account like this guy so now
let's talk about the threads and let's
talk about how you can protect yourself
against it some feedback from us and
some from DHS number one political
misinformation deep fakes can be used to
create videos of politicians saying or
doing things they never did this could
potentially manipulate public opinion
Insight unrest or even influence the
outcomes of Elections number two fraud
criminals could use deep fakes to
impersonate individuals for the purpose
of fraud such as creating false identity
proofs or faking video calls to trick
victims into revealing sensitive
information or sending money that's
pretty interesting that can happen to a
lot of Boomers elderly people hey Ma hey
Grandma can you give me the credit card
information again and they will number
three is Corporate Espionage this is
when deep fakes can be used in person
CEOs or other high-ranking officials
potentially leading to stack
manipulation spreading of corporate
misinformation or tricking employees
into revealing confidential information
so imagine an Elon Musk comes out and
says I've decided to sell Tesla I'm
retiring I don't want to work anymore
boom stock drops 20 percent these are
the types of things that could happen
number four blackmail and defamation
deep fakes could be used to create
compromising or damaging images or
videos of individuals for the purpose of
blackmail or character assassination
number five spread of fake news depicts
can make fake news stories seem more
credible by providing seemingly real
video or audio evidence to support false
claims legal implications deep fake skin
potentially undermine the legal system
by creating false evidence that could be
used to sway court cases or mislead
investigations this could be used by
criminals to kind of falsify that that
wasn't really me and more importantly
imagine if that's actually being used by
some dark dirty evil politician and
government employees to go after
innocent people it's a little scary
number seven National Security Risk by
impersonating political military or
other leaders deep fakes could
potentially pose threat to National
Security even potentially triggering
military responses based on false
information number eight social unrest
deep fakes can be used to incite
violence and create social unrest by
portraying incidents that never occurred
or by Fanning existing social tensions
for example do you remember when Jesse
smallett was like I was out there and
these two African men came and they had
Mega hats on and they're screaming Mecca
and America lost their minds I can't
believe racism still exists and then all
of a sudden took us a few days to
realize that wasn't real it was fake it
was his way his contract was coming up
he was trying to get a raise it created
such tension and Division in America
that was a real person doing a deep fake
now imagine if he could have made the
video showing that that happened and it
wasn't the fake and you and I fell for
it imagine that it's very possible that
that can happen wouldn't be surprised if
it does actually happen number nine
erosion of trust as deep fakes become
more prevalent they could contribute to
a general erosion of trust and video and
audio media causing confusion and
cynicism among the public about what is
real and what is not and last but not
least invasion of privacy depicts can
infringe on people's privacy by using
their images or voices without their
consent or by creating false scenarios
involving them they can also be used to
create non-consensual explicit content
which is serious violation of personal
privacy so how do you protect yourself
against this stuff because by the way if
you're watching this you have to know
this is coming no matter how much the
government's like well you can't do this
and you can't do that a 12 year old kid
can take this and do this and create a
tick tock profile you know even right
now there's a parody account of AOC
obviously what's been happening with
this going back and forth how AOC
doesn't want to pay for a verified
account and this other parity account is
Dr if you haven't read some of these
tweets on what AOC has said let me read
three of them to you tell me how funny
this is but it's a parenting account we
should have 14 768 separate Pride days
one day for every gender now that's
pretty dumb and that's not AOC but it's
a priority account but it's so real
because it's verified and the other one
isn't it's a form of a deep fake that's
getting people to be confused a bit if
we don't move to 100 green energy soon
car emissions will kill off the human
race just like it did with Dinosaurs
[Laughter]
that's right next to next to the car
emissions
again it's getting some people that
don't really look at this stuff say I
can't believe you ever she said
something like this every time my
boyfriend farts I make him plant a tree
to offset his carbon emissions now that
one she may have said I I'm I can see
she's capable of saying that but it's
actually a parody Count saying that so
be fakes we got to be aware of them how
to protect yourself number one media
literacy one of the best defenses
against deep fakes is to be media
literate understand that not everything
seen on the Internet is real even if it
looks and sounds like a real person be
skeptic and always double check what's
out there go look at other accounts and
other news sites to see if they're
saying it as well if not maybe hang
tight before you share that with other
people number two verify information if
a video or audio clip seems suspicious
or add a character for the person
involved verify it from multiple sources
before you believe or share it number
three use detection tools there's a lot
of different detection tools out there
one of them we noticed was called a
deepware DOT AI but you can find many of
them to see if something is fake or it's
real number four maintain privacy be
careful about what images and
information you share online the more
images and videos of your available on
the internet the easier it is for
someone to create a convincing defect of
you perfect then I'm screwed number five
set up alerts considering setting up
Google alerts for your name to monitor
new content associated with your name
that appears on the internet number six
report deep fakes if you come across a
deep fake or if you find yourself the
victim of one report it number seven
legislative support advocate for
legislation and regulations that protect
against the malicious use of The Fakes
number eight be careful in online
Communications be wary of strange or
unexpected requests in video calls
especially if they involve sensitive
information number nine you secure
encrypted communication platforms for
sensitive matters consider using secure
communication platforms that employ
strong encryption to prevent
unauthorized access and number 10
awareness and education lastly raising
awareness about the existing and
potential harm of defects is crucial the
more people are aware the issue the less
likely they are to be fooled by them and
by the way I'll read you some of the
advice dhsk for identifying deep fakes
blurring dividend the face but not
elsewhere in the video or the image a
range of skin tone near the edge of the
face double chins double eyebrows or
double edges on the face whether the
face gets blurry when it is partially
obscured by a hand or another object
lower quality sections throughout the
same video box like shapes and crops
affected around the mouth eyes and neck
blinking movements that are not natural
changes in a background or lighting
varying tone inflection and speech
phrasing with the speaker say that way
context of the message is it relevant to
recent discussion or can they answer
related questions anyways just be aware
of it this is real it's here it's not
going away I guess what this does is
kind of teach us to go back to what it
was before I would assume in 1980s the
average person didn't have a phone if
the husband and wife are on a phone call
at five o'clock and the husband's
leaving work and they get into a bad
fight he's got a 40-minute ride to the
house he's not texting every second to
say what he feels like it he's got 40
minutes to cool down before he gets home
and says hey what was that all about
right and then they can do what they
want to do
today when you're seeing something don't
immediately feel the need to react to it
by the way we are all part of this Camp
because we're like what is this so
rather is this real can you is this
really real hey Johnny is this real can
you check the circle it's not okay it's
a deep fake got it nope this this
thing's very realistic guy look at this
here and then move on verify it before
you jump to conclusion on defects you're
gonna see because this is the future
it's not going away so now there's a lot
of people that all they think about is
negative with AI but there's a lot of
ways to use a on a positive way
especially Chad gbt we did a video
titled seven ways to use Chad gbt in a
positive way if you've never seen a
click here to watch it if you got value
from the video thumbs up subscribe to
the channel take everybody bye
foreign
[Music]